he's Reggie Aloysius Miller no game this
week and to be a nice gig there TNT the
Hall of Famer back on the program
hi reg how are you you tell me what a
good gig I know who took yesterday off
because they had this sniffle don't look
I play hurt we play hurt
did you ever nipple he have a little
cold did you take some Advil aspirin are
you feeling better
Theodora Paulie actually sent a priest
to my house for last rites yeah but I'm
here today you're a trooper you're a
gamer come on man your gamer and I live
on 34th Street so it's Miracle on 34th
Street it's a different version but it's
a miracle I'm here today reg alright
okay how many ejections did you have in
your career oh I would probably say
anywhere between 5 to 10
McLovin how many oh how long does that
include like fighting and then getting
ejected right yeah that includes that
right ok I would say I would say 8
McLovin according to STATS Inc you have
18 18 18 I need to talk to the
commissioner to get some of that money
back because some of them were not
warranted some were but some weren't I
would say of those 18 17 words fight
related well I go back to the game
against the Bulls and this is 1993 you
got tossed when you and Jordan fought
Jordan wasn't even given a foul again I
I tell this story
this is probably my all-time favorite MJ
story because he and I were going at it
this is in Market Square Arena my
buildings our building the Pacers
building this happened in the first
quarter maybe the second quarter we get
tangled up and we start fighting and we
start the one blows at one another we
both start fighting we both throw
how do I get tossed out in my building
and he goes on to score 45 which he
probably would have had if I would have
hit in the game but still I get thrown
out of my building in Indiana and black
Jesus the golden boy who was obviously
the number one draw okay I get it I knew
everyone came to see him but how do I
guess roll now do you think it was a
conspiracy I think those three officials
needed to be fined and and or suspended
because they huddled up and they're like
we can't throw my they're all here to
see him and I kinda want to see them too
let's just throw Miller he's only a
fourth-year player see I think Jordan
was upset he wanted you to stay and so
he got 55 instead of 45 what are the
magic words like what really bothers a
referee when you call them a maybe a dog
word possibly a dog a female dog okay
you should never do only BT bleeper or
the one that I probably got tossed the
most by saying to arrest how did you
ever get my god you need to go back to
Division two I got time for that one
yeah yeah why did you ever get this yeah
what do you think LeBron said last night
to get tossed he probably said you
effing dog you effing sucks and that
probably did it I don't agree with the
official saying he charged me and I felt
threatened come on now that's ridiculous
don't get scared we're playing
professional now sit only say some six
foot eight nine 250-pound rushed you and
you got here no but he did say the magic
word
it's magic words as opposed to his
actions like running up on him no it was
the words what what was the one tirade
that you heard by somebody like where
you went oh my god the probably the best
one
and I'm sure Polly can pull this up as
I'm explaining it
we're playing Chicago again ironically
in Chicago this is my second or third
year Chuck person is just going off on
the official it was a bad call he picks
up the basketball and starts kicking it
into the stands and I leave after I
believe the official was Billy Oates
throws him out and gets into his face
the ball somehow from the stands
someone threw it back onto the court he
picks it up again and kicks it again
into the stands it was the funniest
thing he just he just kick it into the
stands but the official bill Oates is
running up into Chuck's face and shut to
his credit was trying to get away from
the official but the official is just
like glue I mean you would never see an
official in today's game run up to a
player and get into his face like the
old school officials used to do and he
is just like lighting into chucks I'm
like oh my god Here I am as a second
third year playing like this league is
crazy absolutely literally crazy but it
was the most hilarious thing to see
Chuck kicking this ball into the stands
it was just brilliant cuz I haven't seen
it since but it was just it was just
great theater he's a Reggie Miller Hall
of Famer NBA on TNT analyst you have the
Lakers in Golden State coming up tonight
and I don't know if this is a situation
where Golden State goes out of its way
to embarrass Lonzo ball remember the
comparisons that you know Lavar Ball
said Lanza will be better than Steph
Curry that does this does this play a
role any role whatsoever not that they
need that to embarrass somebody but I
don't know how it works in the inner
circle in the NBA when stuff like this
is said and then you go out and play
against somebody
it's absolutely discussed on the bus
it's absolutely discussed in the locker
room and
absolutely discussed on the plains now
well they make a point to go out and
embarrass them no they'll play their
game I think they're more embarrassed by
losing to Sacramento at home and they'll
come out and want to play well to get
back on the right footing but because
they're going against Alonzo ball and
we're gonna put him through a million
pick and rolls and we're gonna feed
Steph the ball so he can embarrass him
know they'll play their game but the
point of levar wall saying his son was
better than Steph those things are
absolutely discussed and I'm sure
they'll make a point I'm sure
Pachulia and draymond Green will
probably lay extra wood on Lonzo ball
but it's absolutely discussed but I
don't think he'll be the highlight of
what the Warriors want to do tonight
because they were already embarrassed by
losing the Sacramento at home I think
they want to come out and play well and
if there's a statement made during that
game I'm sure it will be made but it's
one of those games you want to watch
because of what again papa ball putting
his kids I tell you every game is gonna
be like this for long so and it's not
fair to him it was never fair to him but
this is what's gonna happen explain to
me the situation in Memphis what's going
on there and where you fired the coach
Marc Gasol is he gonna be traded and by
all accounts you know the players you
know fist Dale would say was a good
coach good man in the jungle a great
players coach a great man and to me I
thought one of the fantastic young minds
in our games in terms of X's and O's
comes from a great pedigree of the Pat
Riley tree obviously under bowls row
where he was an associate head coach
want to championships there so this is
leaving a lot of people scratching their
head but again we don't know the
internal workings of what was going on
in that locker room
and for Marcus all to be upset who's
your all-star center and one of your key
players on this team along with Mike
Conley it's a difficult situation to be
in but certainly from the outside
looking in from the optics something was
going on eternally with this team for
them to lose what 11 of 12
him it's very because they have too much
talent on this team and I know the West
is loaded but for them to be on a losing
streak like this with that type of
talent I think if your ownership in the
GM you try to nip it in the bud early
and obviously I always tell people this
the coaches are always the scapegoats
they're always the first to go it's
unfortunate in this situation because I
like fizz I think he's a great coach I
think he'll land on his feet somewhere
else but it is certainly head-scratching
to see him go this early in the season
and it's head-scratching and it's sad
that I have to let you go right now
can I just say this before I go yeah I
do feel for Eli I really do I've known
Eli for a while obviously through Peyton
in our times when he would come visit is
his big brother in Indiana to have 210
consecutive starts and then to find out
next week you've been benched
I felt the emotions when he was talking
to that presser so I feel from there's
always light at the end of the tunnel
Eli I hope you get your gig back at some
point in time but it happens Thank You
reg enjoy the week off we'll talk to you
next week
you're the best you know I hope you said
hey you get some rest okay all right
okay I hope you feel better baby all
right
Thank You reg thank you thank you taking
my last breath here for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]